how's it going bros my name is Peter Pan
welcome to the house of creep 3 by the
haitani escape again but now I made it
more harder and scarier that's what she
said
let's try this out all right
[Music]
all right here we are haha I missed you
we haven't talked in a while I pity
serious why did we map you're always
busy and they're too busy to talk to
mister scheck I do so much thing out
please please mr. shams alright welcome
back again now that our motorway stopped
you good luck I don't like that hey hey
that's baby I am Clayton Stefano alright
play edition or not hey that's a tiny
tiny boy huh
are they smaller how that's pity I know
I am NOT the girl in addition but it's
okay you know I am very close to
Savannah even though I am not good at
that yes I am okay why are they so small
hey that was a big one that's where
she's a Ladin and that price I mean I
asked what okay all right oh my penis oh
oh
mr. Sheridan you aren't I'm sorry Peter
I was trying but you never listen to me
how's gonna be share more acumen but no
damn it
look at that ass just look at that
fluffy ass just take this leg
put it here and then we take the arm and
Dan a bit I was just trying to hug you
up at you like that but don't turn him
to pick on me love you dad down team
frigate if racket afraid wait a second
alright there we go
better buddy make you guys I'm out of
here Jason guys I got a key though
something has to happen everything all
right tell buck naked I come back I'm
back guess who's back
telephone ringing guys god damn you're
sexy I love you I miss peach mr. chair
Aurora right like his father Betty
that's you when you were born god damn
you you're ugly
I'm sorry what what what it hey that's a
weird door I don't know if I dare do
this [ __ ] someone's gonna happen hey a
sledgehammer that's my face hammer hey
nothing happened well what do you know
look get out of here playing a game at
stupid bucks every senior another pimp
sign
all right pity I take them away we are
what huh are you with me or what tell me
all right
yes you should open it huh fine whatever
you say Oh
[Applause]
chairman chairman may I I think it's
cool they just hanging around
oh no you're out of all you scream
I'm gonna take mr. taebel with me happy
little table ever all right we got a key
of some site
I'm sure it goes away machine no it's
always a machine
barrels oh no even more barrels oh I did
not shout look at that
lucky Peters pants had the barrels are
scared
oh no vision a man a man a mr. pot why
would the eye
you're not even breaking I still need
for dramatic flair you God
ah sniffing he knew it was the our
Father wasn't it
I heard you scream Peter are you all
right okay I don't even know what I'm
supposed to go penis ah teleport
teleport me guys [ __ ] words
I'll never was supposed to go Jesus
Christ machine room I invented the
machine room I hate all of you so severe
dad you can't do [ __ ] Brown you can't do
[ __ ] breath okay why are we going where
we going with the drunken sailor wait I
got a hammer though Megan do hammer time
or something I don't know maybe the
stones BAM
I didn't work maybe big thing here oh
[ __ ] that's kept me
alright mission table I'm gonna call you
mayonnaise best name ever Mayo Mayo the
Mayo net
nothing like all right let's just go bad
anyway
is this a machine room no all right all
right fine fine good I'm happy for you
Brad hey a dagger the knife the key is
in his heart
maybe the bro it could be maybe need to
go back or something I think yeah [ __ ] I
must escape that's not good
you shouldn't slant an egg thing I heard
you fry a pity I don't like I swear all
the time what's the problem
yeah you're right where's the bro
where's the bro my thinking thing stove
Lucy sorry yes in here no sighs just
teleported me oh okay okay I get it fell
down he is in his penis no the keys
inside that was give me some girls are
all right fine
I come on McKee is in his heart stupid
stop it where is it I don't write in
this but wasn't right alright there's
key here I [ __ ] missed it I'm sorry
I'm so sorry all right
this isn't everybody hey barrels what
are you doing here
I don't just this one bit hey now the
King oh it's gonna cause anybody else
you're taller I know it's always the
barrels I was buffer haha stupid crap
hey a ladder for me thank you have
another cake that means we can go here
maybe yay I made fast first thing Ealing
meaning we'll land without cheating of
course I don't I know karate
[Music]
[Applause]
mei-mei man hi Jeff I said
Oh Java are you sure yeah ah
this is adorable okay
Hey look at my yeah I love your family
this loling he's like long it's a very
noise ha ha ha oh yeah I look on it it's
all looks like link from Zara and oh my
god yeah I'll be fun is my favorite this
one's name is Reubens mom
at the tongue yeah thank you
you back yet look at yo your entire body
and he said oh look I saw them they were
kissing oh it's the pre cute
nothing yareta nothing yeah I can throw
this much not my neighbors must think
I'm freaking crazy Allah all their best
friends that's cute
I'm gonna end up here both I don't know
if I'll make another video today my
stomach hurts
that was horrible that was freaking I
don't even know I'm just gonna like it
favorite if you enjoyed bros subscribe
to come bro today I should just want to
look at kitty cats I like the car
where's the kissing I want to see them
kiss it's so cute
look at this one and yeah I can edit
here like a fifty dollar house I've seen
everyone
[Music]
you